- Ce sonments sur la capitale
depuis la mi-avril.
Et c'est cet immeuble
par un missile.
"J'ai entendu une premièredit
cette femme, puis une autre.
J'ai eu très très peur
comme les bombardements de
la Deuxième Guerre mondiale."
Larissa habite, elle,
un appar
"On a senti notre immeuble
bouger. rer, dit-elle.
J'ai pensé : 'Ça y est,
on va mourir'."fice étaitfice é.
Seuls les étages du bas
étaient déjà habités.
Et c'est là, dans les décombres,
que les secouristes ont
la journaliste ukrainienne
Vira Hyrych. Elle t
pour Radio Liberty, un média
financé par les États-Unis.
n'avait pas encore ouvert
ses portes. L'équipement
n'est pas trop touché,
mais c'est un dur coup
pour le
dit-il, pour notre pays,
pour notre famille
Il faut tout recommencer."
avoir plutôt touché l'usine
d'armement située ôté.
"Les forces russeuit
avec des armes de haute
précision de longue portée
spatiale Artiom", a déclaré
le porte-parole du ministère
russe de la Défense. C'est un cp
des résidents des alentours,
parce qu'ils commencent à peine
à revenir dans la ville,
après le retraitpays.pays.pays..
Un rappel que, même s'ils sont
chez eux, ils ne sont
pas à l'abri.
"Les Rues à Marioupol,
à Kharkiv, à Boutcha.Ils s'enIl"
Et elle nous montre sur
son téléphone la maisonit.
Il y avait deux étages,
il ne rien.
Plus rien."
Natalia est venue déposer
quelques fleurs, une pensée
pour ceux qui ont été touchés.
"Je ne ressens que de la haine,
de la colère et du désespoir,
aire."
Et surtout, Natalia saitla proe
de ces bombardements.
Céline Galipeau,
Radio-Canada, Kiev.